non voilà je me permets de répondre au
titre non c'est non pour ceux qui se
demandent quoi je parle avec norman on a
imaginé une mini série qui s'appelle
presque adulte et qui sera diffusée cet
été à la télé et sur youtube
thual avis à marc ça se passe bien sûr y
oublie tout cette mini série a été
financée par tf1 et fanta et le premier
épisode va être diffusée attention le
samedi 8 juillet à 20h45 à la télévision
et deux semaines plus tard sur youtube
et depuis que ça a été annoncé en fait
c'est d'ituri n'importe quoi sur
internet
alors moi je vais répondre aux
commentaires maintenant ils quittent
youtube pour la télé manon non monsieur
comme j'ai dit la série sera aussi sur
youtube et c'était très important pour
nous c'était même une condition si la
série ne pouvait pas sur youtube on ne
la faisait pas bon et surtout ça rien
changé à mes vidéos en fait je continue
comme d'habitude ça c'est juste un
projet supplémentaire à côté c'est
cadeau c'est gratuit ça me fait plaisir
c'est pour vous un an mais j'insiste à
généraux ça parle de quoi presque adulte
on est trois personnages natu norman et
moi même on joue un peu nos propres
personnages et on parle de notre
difficulté à être des adultes
moi je peux de demain sur nos bonnes
occupe une inquiétante rabais on se rend
compte double par exemple il ya un
épisode ou norman doit garder sa nièce
un épisode ou natu et un repas de
famille un épisode où ma mère dans la
série veut jeter mes jouets d'enfants et
ça ça me fait mal au coeur
on voulait raconter le décalage qui
avait entre nos parents qui nous
prennent toujours pour des gamins petit
cyprien c'est l'équipe en gc crottes de
nez et les jeunes qui nous prennent pour
des dieux nous le titre presque du catch
il ya plein de personnages ya plein de
décor et à plein de petites aventures on
parle pas du tout de notre métier de
youtube heures on parle vraiment de nous
en tant que jeune adulte qui galèrent
ongles avec nos parents avec les jeunes
ils vont poster moins de trucs sur
youtube alors pas du tout non même pour
ma part c'est même le strict inverse
j'ai pris de plein de choses sur la
chaîne youtube des courts métrages et
même un petit projet secret qui est
prévu pour cet été
gentil pas plus à chaque projet secret
ils perdent leur indépendance à la
télévision ça c'est très intéressant
parce que je sais pas comment ça se
passe pour les autres séries mais en
tout cas nous ni fatalité f1 vous a fait
de retour sur les scénarios ils ont pas
changé une seule virgule on était
totalement libre on a écrit ça avec
norman flaubert et julien jousse là
entre aux gars du net tout simplement et
puis surtout c'était une aventure super
intéressante à vivre deux semaines de
tournage avec nat ou avec norman est un
peu intense mais c'était super
intéressant et puis on a fait plein de
rencontres que j'en ai un très bon
souvenir j'ai hâte que ça sorte
c'est différent des sketches youtube oui
c'est vrai on a voulu tester quelque
chose de nouveau créer une continuité
sur dix épisodes la même thématique avec
des personnages qui avancent dans leur
histoire en quoi c'est différent on joue
déjà des personnages plus crédible a pas
des benchs line tout en un montage
énervé avec eux des zooms comme ça des
petites phrases qui apparaissent
pourquoi pêche porte une perruque jingle
perruque voilà ça sera pas ça du tout et
surtout cette série c'est une
collaboration il ya un réalisateur il ya
un monteur il ya une production il ya
quelqu'un qui a composé la musique sont
au générique c'est une grande équipe qui
a fait ça ça c'est presque adulte et
ensuite si vous voulez des trucs que je
suis tout seul c'est plus les vidéos
tout seul ils ont vendu leur âme à la
télé et m et écoute depuis depuis tout à
l'heure en plus tu me ressemblent
beaucoup et c'est blé sont super du
contenu supplémentaire je regarderai
tous les épisodes de presque adulte
chaque semaine ça qui me ressemble
énormément à 6 mg je vous donne donc
rendez vous le samedi 8 juillet à 20h45
pour le premier épisode et deux semaines
plus tard sur youtube n'hésitez pas à
mettre un pouce en l'air devant votre
télé devant internet voilà même dans la
rue sion de croiser ou qui pousse en
l'air et moi je vous en dis plus très
rapidement sur ce petit projet top
secret
[Musique]
ça c'était le générique en exclusivité
juste pour toi et maintenant ce que tu
as peur tu sais que tu vas cliquez sur
le bouton au milieu ouais tu cliques sur
ton smartphone avec ton doigt et tu
pourras tu abonnés comme ça tu pourras
voir toutes les prochaines vidéos le
projet secret la série presque adultes
choisis clique qui doit-on smartphones
vas-y bas cyclique